[Applaudissements]
alors je vais vous demander d'avoir un
petit peu d'imagination
et d'imaginer que je suis allongée sur
un canapé
co budgétaire vous comprenez
j'ai l'impression de faire une séance
chez le psy
en même temps de son pied rien que pour
moi
je suis plutôt flatté
et c'est vrai je suis flatté
et très content d'être là devant vous
je me présente je suis Cassandre avec un
K
puis
ostéopathe dans mon cabinet et je suis
aussi sapeur-pompier volontaire
ça fait tellement longtemps que vous
savez on arrête de compter quand ça fait
10 ans 9 mois et 29 jours
j'ai aussi une femme formidable
un logo à mon effigie
un chien une chatte trois souris enfin
que demande le peuple
mais vous allez me dire c'est génial
mais je vous aurais pas cru encore il y
a quelques temps pour en arriver là j'ai
quand même du battre et faire des choix
un peu contre tout attendre mais je vous
explique revenons un peu en arrière
j'ai toujours eu envie d'être pompier
mais je ne sais pas depuis quand ça
remonte
j'ai envie de dire j'ai pas signé mes
parents apparemment très tôt
et il pense que ça vient de la naissance
de ma sœur
alors oui j'étais là dans la salle
d'accouchement à ce moment-là qui
n'était autre que le salon
elle est arrivée beaucoup plus vite que
prévu
donc du coup l'accouchement s'est fait à
la maison
avec les pompiers et moi pendant ce
temps-là j'avais 3 ans et j'ai réussi à
ouvrir la porte d'entrée
[Applaudissements]
et
j'ai toujours eu envie de réaliser de
vivre de mes passions notamment le sport
le judo surtout mais d'aider les gens
et
médecins humanitaire
j'ai le cas de professionnels
archéologue de renommée ça fait super
classe mais ces trois vies en une donc
oui quand on a 10 ans tout est possible
on va se calmer pompier ça répond plutôt
bien aux critères
sapeurs-pompiers j'ai réussi à être à
l'âge de 12 ans
je suis à mes 17 ans
à 17 ans et trois mois je signe comme
sapeur-pompier volontaire donc je monte
enfin dans les mythiques camion rouge je
sauve des gens je réalise des
accouchements
j'adore ce que je fais
mais
ce que je vous raconte est plutôt génial
[Musique]
mais il n'y a pas que des fins heureuses
la vraie vie est plus dure
la vraie détresse des gens est plus dur
à voir
et elle est encore plus quand elle nous
touche
et dès 2012 j'ai 17 ans et 9 mois j'ai
eu mon bac je rentre de vacances je
profite avant mon entrée en prépa
et ma mère fait un malaise
comme je suis sur place je switch
directement et inconsciemment en mode
pompier c'est clair dans la tête je sais
quoi faire comment faire tout va bien se
passer
elle fait un arrêt cardiaque
je fais le massage j'appelle les
pompiers en même temps
ils arrivent vite mais ça part une
éternité
elle est finalement transportable à
Paris
on nous dit rupture d'anévrisme je
connais pas donc on attend
une semaine d'attente
plusieurs chirurgies
le verdict tombe
les dommages au cerveau sont trop
importants
le ciel me tombe sur la tête
maman c'est éternel normalement
j'avais jamais vu une autre possibilité
et ma mère c'était le pilier de la
famille
et cette fameuse famille
s'écroule aussitôt
alors
revient au galop je fais tout pour
combler toutes les fissures j'aide à
l'entrée en CP de mon petit frère je
fais le soutien pour ma sœur je fais
tout ce que je peux être aidante pour
mes grands-parents notamment j'ai une
grand-mère qui a des problèmes moteurs
un grand père kaizehzimer et de temps en
temps j'essaie de suivre mes cours
mes études ont on dirait sept ans nous
en prépa 5 ans d'école d'ostéopathie et
pendant ce temps
j'étais aidante j'étais pompier j'étais
grande sœur avec des petits boulots pour
mettre un peu de beurre dans les
épinards
c'était compliqué mais j'ai pas lâché
et surtout les pompiers
parce qu'en fait la détresse des gens
devenait insupportable ça devenait la
mienne
et quelle idée de faire
autant d'études tout ça quand on a pas
d'argent parce que les études coûtent un
bras
et surtout quand on n'a pas la
disponibilité émotionnelle
évidemment bon nombre de mon entourage
attendez juste que je tombe
mais non enfin pas trop déo des bas des
très bas vive les champs
mais deux choses ont vraiment
permis d'avancer la première était assez
involontaire d'une part d'une collègue
un jour où j'ai pris ma garde elle me
dit mais dis donc tu ne pleures pas
aujourd'hui lui répondre en public quand
même
mais ça m'a amené à me questionner il y
a un truc qui tourne pas rond chez moi
du coup bah j'ai consulté un psychologue
je m'attendais à faire une séance qui me
répondait à ma question et puis c'est
fini
que je suis
bon ben voilà mais ces séances m'ont
permis
et ont été vraiment déclencheur de
tellement de bonnes choses après
grâce à ça j'ai pu me construire ma
famille de cœur avec mon pareil et ma
marraine
j'ai pu aussi m'ouvrir aux rencontres
bienveillantes
et surtout accepter la nouvelle ligne le
nouveau chemin que prenait ma vie alors
le changement c'est angoissant j'ai
angoissé
mais on arrive quand même avoir de
bonnes choses
la deuxième chose qui m'a permis
d'avancer
c'est que je ne voulais pas la décevoir
parce qu'en fait je savais qu'elle
voulait que je réussisse ma vie
et pour y arriver il faut d'abord y
croire
alors quand j'ai comme moi une confiance
en Vous digne du zéro absolu à peu près
c'est compliqué
et bah laissez croire qu'un délégué
c'est elle qui a cru en moi et j'ai
réussi à avancer
j'ai toujours gardé en tête comme quoi
elle voulait que je réussisse ma vie que
je vive de mes passions que je vive ma
passion
aider et être aidé n'est pas
complètement incompatible j'ai même
souvent complémentaire
mais il faut être capable de s'ouvrir
pour voir les opportunités
vous savez moi je ne crois pas qu'il est
de bonne ou de mauvaise situation
si je devais résumer ma vie avec vous
aujourd'hui
je dirais que c'est avant tout des
rencontres des gens qui m'ont tendu la
main peut-être à un moment où je ne
pouvais pas j'étais seule chez moi
je vois des bons là ça c'est bien
désolé pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris
s'en est d'accord qu'elle est
complètement vraie
c'est les rencontres que l'on fait qui
nous permettent d'avancer et de devenir
les personnes exceptionnelles que l'on
peut et que l'on doit devenir
oui le chemin est difficile mais il faut
pas lâcher
on peut y arriver
et maintenant je peux vous dire que
j'aime ma vie
j'aime ce que je fais je vis ma passion
et je vis de ma passion moi j'en ai une
toutes les semaines de nouvelles
mais profitez de la vie
vivez passionné et vivez passionnément
mais pour y arriver il faut d'abord y
croire
je me sens déjà mieux à vous avoir parlé
n'empêche
je vois combien pour la séance
[Applaudissements]